das ist von erstaunt was wir gerade
sixpack auf warum passiert so was meine
damen und herren die zeit ist gekommen
wir haben uns versammelten unserem
professionellen youtube scheißdreck
kritik raum an seiner seite ist heute
enden eminem ist heute hier bei max
meinte er hätte keine lust mehr zu
reagieren schöne serie gesprungen sind
nur die besetzung der heutigen folge ist
damit auch geklärt ich bin da eher
männern ist da und damit können jetzt
dazu übergehen was ihr alle gewartet
habt und zwar das nächste absolutes
video community und zwar dreht sich
heute alles um das video wie die
kardashian ist meine töchter brauchen
ein sextape schauen an die beschreibung
christi 43 hat das sagt jedenfalls
dreimal umzudrehen die arbeitslosenhilfe
die arbeitslose alleinerziehende mutter
von nina leila und justin wenn sich
endlich etwas gehört und nicht immer am
existenzminimum leben sie hat schon eine
geniale idee wie sie das ganz große geld
machen kann selbst vor einem sexvideo
der eigenen tochter schreibt die mutter
nicht zurück ein must go bjb
ist doch okay ich glaube aber dass auch
wieder keine ahnung wo ich habe die
erste soll ich sagen es ist die erste
reise kommt schon gesehen ich kann mir
schon vorstellen
der mann braucht einen text hält und die
sunfilm
wir fahren keine chance mehr einmal ist
er auf sein schloss zurück wo er
irgendwie zu verhindern dass die tochter
das tatsächliche alter kann man noch die
herumrennen und mehr geht nicht
was ist das für ein video
das seriöse riesigen jahrmarkt ende
werde die tatsache dass das samsung
profitieren das geht gar nicht an der
stelle
und ganz kurz auch seit wann ist man bei
dem sex tape angezogen funktioniert das
so weil ich mich nicht hat mich nochmal
katja verlieren glaube ich angefangen
auf die mich backstage ist das was sie
jetzt machen könnten
leila paul der sonst in afrika ist
abwärts kurz dass sie ihre tochter und
ihren sohn gefilmt
auch wenn ich weiter ins essen kommt so
bekommen bei mir jetzt aber überrascht
was sie da stehen die sagen guck dir mal
den größenunterschied zwischen den
beiden alter können sie an ihrem
gaumenkitzel lang ist er niemals wie alt
ist er
das ist doch nina 18 das ist leider 14
vielleicht meine die größe in
zentimetern warum was macht ihnen der
mutter können
für die familie reich und bekannt machen
und die meisten kinder machen wir nicht
mit uns also ein player
du willst nicht glauben was sie da
gemacht die aussagen genommen also ich
beim sex gefilmt kleine rote direktion
ist so untertrieben
hast du uns gefehlt so als wäre das
überhaupt eine sache die man sich
überhaupt vorstellen kann
das ist passiert die eigene mutter hat
einen gerade beim geschlechtsakt gefilmt
das kann ich euch erklären ja ihr seid
doch wunderschöne menschen hallo ich
bringe euch ganz groß raus ihr werdet
ihr werdet könnt ihr ohne probleme auch
mit einem zirkus umherziehen
hexenmeister in seiner kleinen hexen
hexen schreibt nichts gemacht und
kommentare - so die paul paul du bist
die mutter wendi hilft mir aufnehmen
will
das video sollte man endlich einmal
wieder im bett ist der bachelor ist
ich glaube da kommt aus detroit also im
norden moskaus ist eine kiste vegas
verbesserte leben einfach ein bisschen
im kinderpornografie rausfahren
aufgespannt ist das ganze bis 14 ja noch
mal schlimm genug wenn die tochter
erwachsen ist so wie bei sowas höchsten
oder wird sie jetzt verflucht die
krebszellen aber zu diesem zeitpunkt
muss die top jetzt möglich auch mal
verständlich sein meine aber ganz ganz
kurz stelle dieses bild ich rechne im
moment damit dass sie einfach so auf
hasel so ein flug aus stolz und dabei
ihre kinder so per flug beim
kontrolliert ich glaube ich gehe
[Applaus]
juli / lass uns kurz darüber nachdenken
was wir gerade sehen es ist deutschland
ok und die frau hielt ihre 14 jährige
tochter in der hoffnung dass sie das ins
internet stellen kann und dass wir
berühmt wird überrascht von christie so
ganz selbstverständlich über die
privatsphäre ihrer kinder hinweg
klatscht die gar nicht mitkriegt wie
sieht das vertrauensverhältnis zu ihren
kindern hinterher rennt los weil
irgendwelche anderen menschen die
schönen sind und nichtskönner irgendwie
berühmt geworden sind was ich
interessant
kim kardashian komplett die ehrenwerten
sie nimmt den kann das einfach kommen
wird die irre weil sie hat einfach kein
verständnis dafür dass menschen mit
sinnlosen dingen geld verdienen deshalb
kommentiert sie auch ein fiktives tv
format in größe gehen raus und ich an
dieser stelle jedoch keinen text so
warum spricht sie normalerweise stehe so
rechtsanwalt oder die plötzliche tod
wahrscheinlich
[Gelächter]
der schuss kann aber nicht muss sie
wurde ausgelöst durch die mutter
wahrscheinlich auch pleite weil die
die aus dem knast gelöst habt mich zu
kümmern ja ich versuche gerade euch zu
versorgen aber das steckst du ja nicht
meine mutter trägt doch nicht mehr ganz
richtig stimmt wir fast fast aber nur
fast
ich frage mich was noch passiert das ist
mir fast apathisch sondern richtig
erwartet muss sich die mutter so eine
schweinemast können voraussetzt
hallo komme ich kurz im sexfilm was mir
gerade ein sixpack auf beide sind der
meinung das ist absolut echt
warum passiert sowas bei dem die
einkommen in so einer plastiktüte
karriere mein typ passt natürlich hätte
ja das war erste teil von unser reaktion
heute der zweite kommt morgens noch eine
neue folge von was das geht mit ihr
zusammen für euch und wenn er läuft
könnt ihr einfach irgendwo auf dem
bildschirm auf den button klicken dann
habt ihr gleich zu der frage macht gute
leute youtube bleibt nicht mehr ich soll
mir heute den richtigen job
mal gucken wie das wird
ich habe mich bei der deutschen bank
geworben
[Musik]